last time out martin perez he had the
easiest two innings you could have
in that third inning he came out and
threw some hanging changeups later found
out he had a blister
and a liner sizing it up for dugo he's
got it one man left red sox coming up
in the first walker rolled out a four
seamer a slider a splitter a curveball
and he can sink it too
he's got about six different pitchers
that he'll feature
and the strike three called right over
the inside corner
and he rings him up jackie bradley jr
250 with three home runs connected for
number three
last night 2-2 a high fly ball that is
driven deep to right way back it goes
it is gone jackie bradley jr for the
second night in a row and he puts the
red sox
out in front one to nothing and a line
driving a base hit
chavis is on he was hitting 197 coming
in so he could use a string of them
and he does swing at the 3-0 and he's
popped it up
shallow right field who's going to take
charge davis
can't make the catch and the inning is
still
alive guerrero around a third on the
play and now vladi's coming home and
will be tagged out
how many times are the blue jays going
to make base running mistakes you get a
break ben chavis dropped the ball and
now they run into another out
charlie montoya's got to be beside
himself
2-1 to bogarts swinging a chopper if it
gets over walker it'll be a hit it does
get over him
and it will be a hit santiago espanol
loved it but then bobbled the transfer
and bogey leads off the bottom of the
fourth with an infield knock
jd martinez over one he's grounded to
third
and he'll tag that one for a base hit
bow guards to second red sox have
something going on here in the fourth
inning
all right little infield hit line drive
base hit by jd
one nothing red sox red sox have done
all the hitting
to this point and one of those a home
run by jbj that's the difference
vr will lead things off here in the top
half of the fifth inning
he's over one he's grounded out to third
sox getting a very solid performance
thus far by martine perez
he'll get a ground ball and a high chop
bogarts gets rid of it in a hurry viara
is out despite
the dive into the bag one away he's
telling him to shake
twice and change up again throw the
change up again he's trying to be
trickster
nicely done 85 to strike him out and he
breezes again
one two three
that's the way that disappeared he
struck him out espinoza fans
went away
ground ball gobbled up by denver's in
the second printout on the first close
and double play
red sox will turn two twin killing
pitchers duel here and a base hit
that'll be verdugo for the first time
tonight and only
the fifth hit in the ball game and the
red sox have all of them
on tonight jd is single and he is tapped
to third
weighted on that one and he rips it
it'll go all the way to the wall
rafael denver is on his way into third
base he'll pull up there long
single for j.d whose swing
all of a sudden looks a lot better
3-1 walked him
and that will load up the bases for
jackie bradley jr
and bring out the toronto skipper
he's gonna go get him yep how about that
he might have challenged him if he knew
he was gonna get taken out of this game
i'll tell you what
he is not happy either look at him he is
really upset
and a 3-1 and he walked him
and that will bring in a run red sox
leaded two to nothing
rafael devers into score forced in on
the ball four to jackie bradley jr
hooked down the left field line and
there it is the first hit of the night
off the base of the monster and
hernandez will wisely stop it first
guerrero fly down and now it's gorilla
and he slices one into right field for a
base hit hernandez up to second
well that was a good swing by guriel
lucie's trying to get to him and the
one-two pitch is hit on the ground
into right center of base hit hernandez
rounds third
he's gonna score stopping at second is
guriel
it's an rbi single for joe panic and the
blue jays are on the board in the
seventh trailing two to one
big series for the blue jays very much
in playoff contention
one-two pitch swing and a miss 95 miles
an hour he struck him out with the bases
loaded
the eighth inning might be a much better
shot for the blue jays tonight
than the ninth with the part of the
order that's up as bisho lifts a high
fly ball
left center field and it's going to be
off the monster
bradley has it on a bounce and biggio's
got himself a double
so now second and third with nobody out
infield has come in a bit for the red
sox not all the way to the cut of the
grass
say oscar one for two with a walk on the
night
and he was taken all the way to gets
through vasquez and the tying run will
come home
biggio in to score gretchik to third
and ryan brazier with a balk and
presumably
it'll be scored a wild pitch and the
blue jays have tied it
this is a different situation though
when extra innings second and third one
out you'd love to get one in but
you're thinking damage if you're oscar
hernandez right now and a fly ball to
right
field pretty well hit back
[Applause]
hernandez with an opposite field home
run
and it is 5-2 blue jays 3-1 to guriel
he swings and drives the ball down the
left field line
we don't see it until now and it is foul
or is it is it gone lourdes goriel jr is
circling the bases
and the blue jays have a home run
the blue jays dugout was the first to
react
[Music]
as guriel makes it 6-2 toronto
no two pitch and did he hold on to it
he did and the ball game is over the
blue jays win it
six to two in ten innings tejaska
hernandez
with a huge three-run homer in the top
half of the inning